all right oliver yep oliver where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
um i was born in gothenburg sweden uh
ray's out here in los angeles california
and tell me about your family you had
both your parents
um both my parents like growing up
my dad wasn't around much it was like he
was always working and like busy
cheating like on my mom so is me and my
mom mostly taking care of my two little
sisters
so your parents were from sweden
my dad's from sweden
they stayed out there to have me and uh
my uh my little sister natalie who has
passed away like five years ago
um we were both born out there so
how would you describe your childhood in
general
um super dysfunctional
in what ways
um i was like i was just like a super
problematic kid i think
um i was always doing some [ __ ] that i
wasn't supposed to do
for sure
um
yeah mainly just because i think i was
like scared to like be myself you know
where do you think that came from
um i'm not sure i think like
like problems definitely started like in
school you know and like people are like
have a tendency to be super big pieces
of [ __ ]
like which i might be like one of the
biggest pieces of [ __ ] if i'm gonna
place myself in that category but i got
picked on because i was always like the
shortest dude i'm like five six you know
so i was always like the shortest person
in school so i get picked on a lot
and um
instantly got put into like um like
self-defense training like judo but i
started competing i got really good at
judo i liked it a lot like i got to
exert all that extra energy and
maybe like whatever pain i was feeling
and like anger and stuff like that i got
to release all that training you know so
i trained like
most days out of the week and weekend
and stuff
and uh to the point where like i was
training with dudes that were going to
like the olympics training for the
olympics and i would win like every
contest or tournament i ever went to
like i always got first i got second
place like maybe one time
um
and then i started beating fools up at
school that were picking on me you know
i'm getting kicked out of every school
until i ended up landing in compton
because i couldn't go to school in
torrance anymore
so
how did compton treat you
um
is a white boy they they took me in i
didn't they never treated me like a
white boy
you know
yeah
you finished high school
i did
i did i wasn't living at home so i put
myself through finishing high school i
always promised my mom like no matter
what like how bad i [ __ ] up or whatever
like i'll finish i'll at least finish
high school like that was my promise to
her so that's all she wanted me to do
you know she thought that was going to
be like beneficial or something which
like these days i mean
i don't know
so you left home at what age
six well
like 16 i started getting kicked out
like in and out but 18 i was officially
for sure like not not at home
definitely are you into drugs so always
into drugs
definitely how did that start for you
freshman year high school but um
my grandma was rn she's a registered
nurse
and i found out about like her her pill
cabinet which was in the kitchen which
was like almost every cat like there's
two two really big
cabinets right there and it was just all
opiates like from perks norcos oxies
um super high dosages too
so i was taking like i probably started
taking like
10 800
uh norco's like a day
was like where i was at for a while
um but i pretty much had like a brand
new script like almost every other day
my whole high school career you know so
i was like i was a pill head for sure
where would you after you got out of
high school
um after after high school i still i was
still skating like um that's right like
skateboarding was like the main thing
though like that i got into and like i i
got sponsors right away so my 13th
birthday got like sponsored by board
shop
and i continued to do that until i was
like 21 and i was filming for like a
company i wanted to skate for for a
while and then got injured and then just
didn't have much motivation to like
stay skating i think i was really too
deep into drugs you can't be like
an athlete or athletic and have like a
super bad drug addiction it just doesn't
ever really work out i don't think
i couldn't do it so i had to pick one
you know
i picked opia's
and that led you air
um in jail a lot of times
um hella ods like when i started doing
fat and all
i od'd like once every day for
a month and a half
or something so that's like 30 something
ods like 40 something of these like
[ __ ]
yeah i lost a lot of friends like
throughout that that time time period
for sure
you've been homeless for how long uh
like 12 years
how old do you know
i'm 29. you're 29.
and you're staying in north hollywood
staying in north hollywood right now
like in a uh
an abandoned house you know a bando
yeah so
how do you support yourself
i don't do anything like uh two outside
of
the norm for like being a drug addict
you know like we're out here hustling so
i'll be downtown later macarthur like
hustling off like [ __ ] that i've stolen
like you know they call it boosting now
which is [ __ ] but yeah boosting you
know coming up so otherwise stealing
[ __ ] you'll steal from a story stealing
[ __ ] yeah it's all to a fence who will
resell it exactly yeah or or just
slinging off you know
yeah
how does this affect you emotionally
this lifestyle
um
emotionally
that's a tough one i don't know i think
i'm
uh [ __ ]
i don't know i i think i do this [ __ ] so
i don't have so i'm not so emotional
maybe like i think that's what
the main thing i use like
drugs for you know my father to be more
yeah i don't i don't have to feel
what do you think you're running away
from
uh
[ __ ] i don't even think at this point
that i'm running away from anything like
i'm pretty like content with uh like
things that i've done in my past or just
my past in general you know i'm okay
with that stuff but your childhood was
fairly okay your parents they were there
like it was kind of normal
sexual abuse no sexual abuse no like um
i like i said i was a [ __ ] you know
so i needed a [ __ ] kicked out of me
every once in a while my mom was pretty
good at that
you know i i reminded her a lot of my
dad i think she took a lot of maybe some
of her frustrations out on me a little
bit you know but nothing too crazy she
was a great mom you know
where do you think you get this black
sheep quality from
i have no idea it's like a blessing in a
curse for real like because
if it's not in the household it's
definitely out here like in society too
like it [ __ ] just
i don't i don't even know
i piss people off dude
your friends now
friends
i have uh i have a few like you know a
couple of them and the ones i do have i
keep pretty close you know
[Music]
um but like not not too many bro you
know that all caught friends you know
you've had romantic relationships
romantic relationships like holy [ __ ]
um
no not for a long time romantically like
no i haven't been invested in another
person for a long time you know
what's your typical day look like
as a fentanyl addict
damn like first thing when i wake up i'm
already dabbing so like my torch is
running and just like
uh
i dab like first thing i don't even
think of like
having to do anything you know i just
like i take a hit so i don't feel like
[ __ ] feel good get ready you know move
on with my day and like stealing [ __ ]
within the next hour
it's it's [ __ ] it's pretty bad
but
is this like who you're is is this your
nature to be like stealing from people
no no i don't wake up and i'm like
passionate about having no if you
weren't on drugs would you still be no
no that's the thing when i'm sober i'm
never stealing [ __ ]
i don't no this is just merely out of
like
like survival you know
really
and not wanting to work on nine to five
right
do you think you're bipolar or
i know i'm [ __ ] bipolar
i'm bipolar i've had schizophrenia like
sleep deprivation like if i'm sober i'm
taking every pill that they have for
like most
you know
diagnosis
diagnostics psych meds yeah for sure all
day you do yeah do they help you fine uh
they do yeah yeah my chemical uh
imbalance is
outrageous
yeah
is there anybody else in your family
that's like that
yeah they're all [ __ ] up for sure
it's not as bad like as you know
some worse than others
you know my sister like natalie that
that passed away she had really bad
depression like worse than me she was so
sad you know like she couldn't handle
the world you know
your sister passed away yeah yeah she
died five years ago oh she died she uh
she drowned like but
she had an eating disorder you know she
was a ballerina or something like that
and they said she drank a whole bottle
of like i think it was like rose or
something that you know big bottle of
wine that sits in a black basket that
blue like bougie black chicks drink it
usually
and um
she passed out by the pole
and like fell in and drowned so she was
already unconscious i guess by the time
she hit the water i guess was what they
said
um
it's just like hard for me to believe so
i have a hard time like
you know putting that away
like i just don't see that [ __ ]
happening you know sorry
it happens it's all right
what are you afraid of at this point in
your life
[Music]
uh maybe like dying alone you know
dying alone like
uh
not [ __ ]
getting clean and healthy and
pursuing something within the realm of
skating
and art you know music
do you think there's a better chance of
you
[Music]
dying out here than getting clean for
sure
yeah
have you tried to get clean
yeah yeah so many times
yeah i was just in rehab for two years
you know and then did college while i
was there to become a drugging alcohol
counselor
and pretty much got my degree you know i
was going to work at tarzana
i was just like one step away from
getting my from officially having a
degree as a
you know a counselor and
i didn't get the hours accumulated as a
uh
as an intern
you know
what do you think pulled you back
is it your own self-destructive
tendencies absolutely yeah yeah it
wasn't somebody you know it was me yeah
yeah
for sure
are there benefits to this lifestyle
um have you had a job before i think so
yeah i've had plenty of jobs
it's a decision
you know as of right now it's i'm not
forced into this position you know would
you describe yourself as miserable or
happy or
no i'm like neither you know i'm just
you know
i'm just like existing i'm just
coexisting i'm fine like i guess
content-ish you know it's not about like
being happy it's just about not
feeling like a piece of [ __ ] every day
or like living my life a certain way to
make somebody else happy you know like
that's what i'm not gonna do
like
i'm not gonna live my life doing what
other people want me to do to make them
feel better about who i am like i'm okay
with
with who i am yeah is it you know
another life that you wanted when you
were younger
it's not another life it just looked
different okay what kind of things did
you want to do
what kind of things do i want to do well
i still do like you know skateboarding
is like something i really want to do
like like on another another level
another scale you know
um i still do a lot of artwork
and um
and making music you know i'll continue
to do those things i might not reach
like a certain
scale you know just like
yeah if you had your life to live all
over again what would you have done
differently
honestly i don't know if it would have
turned out so different
you think this is your
destiny
i think it's been kind of like cut out
um
yeah to a certain degree yeah
your parents were good role models you
think
um
my dad was a good role model model is
like
in the sense of like how not to [ __ ]
be you know i don't want to be anything
like that for
um i think he's like an excuse of like
what a man should be like like a sad
excuse
um
yeah
like where i i don't understand how you
could like have kids and just do
everything in your power like not to
have anything to do with them or and
have any type of responsibility you know
it's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you know i
thought he knows that i tell him he's a
piece of [ __ ] just in case he forgets
you know i remind them sometimes
do you have any good memories of your
childhood
yeah my i was just talking about this
the other day with somebody too like my
first memory like of life like the first
thing i remember was actually like being
in the boxing ring with my dad
like he was training or something and he
actually ended up getting into a fight
in the ring because he's like
temperament he couldn't this guy was
like just too tall like my dad's like my
height you know he has like super long
reaches other dudes and he kept putting
tips on my dad and my dad doesn't like
get hit often he's pretty fast you know
and he just kept getting hit and he got
really mad they got they actually got
down and my dad couldn't come back and
we had to leave and stuff like that my
first memory like
the boxing ring you know those are happy
memories my happy but happy memories
like yeah like i grew up like i got to
take care of my sisters you know i got
to help my mom out like those were happy
memories dude like it was just me and my
sisters like and all we had were it was
like each other
you know that was cool i don't think a
lot of people get to experience that
um yeah me and my sisters were hella
hella close you talking with your family
still
like no not at all
not really
what would you say is your biggest
regret
i don't
maybe like gangbanging
yeah
yeah that [ __ ] got me in a lot of
trouble you know
that hurts people you know
you've done time in jail or prison
yeah i didn't i didn't make it to prison
uh
it certainly seemed like i was trying to
get there you know i didn't get there
though
um
jail a lot of jail a lot of county time
county lids and [ __ ] like that
county is pretty miserable for me though
because i run black you know like
outside my race it's not outside my area
somewhere i'm supposed to be at
technically in
a
political perspective
but um
[Music]
yeah like last time i went and i ran
black like i had eight people lined it
up to [ __ ] me up you know what i mean
you say ran black yeah you well in jail
you run by your race you know so like if
you're a gang member like in your
otherwise a normal right white person
like if you were to go to jail you're
going to be with the rest of the whites
you know which there's probably five of
us per dorm or something
opposed to like you know the 27 black
guys and the 46 [ __ ]
mexicans that you have right but you're
supposed to stay with your race but like
me being a gang member you know i'm from
a crypt neighborhood in compton like i
i'll run black
so even though you're swedish you're
hanging out with with blacks blacks
in jail yeah
yeah do you relate to that
group more than yeah you do in ways
in ways
in ways
oliver what do you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
um
like learning how not to fight
are
pretty important
all right oliver thank you so much for
sharing your story thanks for having me
i wish you guys to walk out there thank
you
you